en tant qu'africain ce problème rom du
tchad est le problème de tous les
africains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
le regain des mouvements panafricanistes
parlera par excellence tout ce que nous
nous cherchons est que les africains
prennent conscience de leur force et
qu'il puisse conjuguer une afrique très
unie aujourd'hui il ya 28 puits qui ont
été forés au tchad en puis c'est à peu
près 1000 personnes qui accèdent à l'eau
potable
donc c'est 28000 personnes qui
maintenant ou accès à l'eau potable de
manière durable
affable en dix ans l'artiste hervé gay
le reggae caritatif dans les sens c'est
une musique universaliste qui concerne
tout le monde pas uniquement les
africaines mais tous ceux qui souffrent
et tout ce qu'il ya de la justice le
reggae c'est une communauté en fait les
gens adhèrent forcément l ensemble sur
le motive de voir que il y a autant
d'engouement autour d'un projet aussi
noble c'est très gratifiant très
réconfortant ça veut dire que cette part
d'humanité que nous défendons hockey est
une réalité
[Musique]